why are you looking at it like that
it's my podcast face okay
welcome back to the general podcast this
episode is brought to you by Squarespace
don't do that building a website you
can't just go zero to a thousand into
the podcast
is like my city that's where I live
that's my sweet spot
again
welcome to the podcast uh this episode
is brought to you by Squarespace over
200 000 companies use it and you can
make your website with it too it's very
easy and an awesome platform go to
squarespace.com Jenna Julian for 10 off
your first purchase for website or
domain or try to free trial also guys me
undies the softest underwear that your
butt will ever feel
nine million butts that means 18 million
cheeks have experienced me undies and
you could be next it's micro model well
incredibly soft what if somebody only
had one cheat well
exception of the rule okay not talking
about them okay but they they still made
a good choice with mayonnaise go to me
undies.com Julian 15 off your first pair
free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guarantee or click the link down below
I'm wearing them right now coincidence
go lay down peachy I'm wearing them
right now too I'm wearing like red oh
cute mine's almost matching mine's like
ladybug ones the red bully short ones I
was wearing these backwards earlier
oh God how did you fit all of your
in the in the butt
new conversation
uh anyway
yeah right when we were just starting to
record there's literally a bird we're
upstairs in our house there's a bird on
the roof literally next to the window
just being so loud we should get them a
bird feeder they're always out there
they're like big black crows I like them
I think that they're nice we should get
that bat thing from Shark Tank oh yeah I
really actually want one of those those
are there bats in this area I don't know
we'll find out it's like a little flat
thing that they crawl up inside of yeah
well so they were marketing it on Shark
Tank as like a natural
anti-mosquito or like pests because the
the bats kill pests and eat bugs and
Nature's Pest Control yeah so they were
selling these little like flat wooden
boxes that you hang up that the bats
like to go up in the a bat hotel or bat
Airbnb yeah B and B yeah whatever
remember Lori was like I think it's a
great idea I just I'm so grossed out so
no I'm out yeah I love that I think
they're cool I think that's a cool idea
and I think a lot of people if they
understand a little bit about it would
probably be like oh that's kind of dope
I'll buy one I like because it's not
like you're like hanging out with the
bats well so depending on where you hang
it they're gonna be like flying around
at night and stuff yeah but I don't mind
flying bats though I feel like it's even
less invasive than a bird feeder or a
birdhouse because yeah I want to get
them a bird feeder right so they could
be loud while we're recording the
podcast yeah I like them
they were just loud we had to wait to
record until they stopped
yapping I like it yapping them beaks I
like it
I want a bat house and a bird feeder I
think would be nice can we call the bat
house Baus
sure
three two one Baus Lane perfect
I think it might drive Birdville
California okay 911 that's the ZIP code
okay
I think if we got either a bird feeder
or a bat house it will provide endless
entertainment for the dogs
entertainment or frustration source of
barking
we don't really know chasing barking and
chasing is behavior that a dog can
exhibit when they're having fun
but it's also Behavior a dog can exhibit
when they're very frustrated and anxious
what is it I never know
they're always barking and chasing
that's not true they're pretty chill
look at Bobby Bobby's just looking and
waiting for a bird to come back it's a
they have groupthink
none of the dogs are individual thinkers
so when marbles makes a peep Kermit is
in full attack mode and he doesn't even
know where he's looking he doesn't know
what what the enemy is Marvel does that
to him too they'll be outside like just
on the patio or whatever and marble will
go at Carmen just go and just like go
made that noise at his head and then
they'll both just start running away
together like we don't know what we're
barking at but we're barking now we're
excited Marvel you worked you got Kermit
in the palm of your hand yeah he likes
it he likes to cause a little stress and
curve it and then marvelous Daenerys
Kermit is gray worm and kerm is just
like who are we getting he's literally
gray worm oh yeah
like I don't know man let's just go this
way we'll find something oh no it
doesn't matter you love me so you'll do
whatever I want
oh
he likes the excitement
like when there is no excitement he
creates the excitement you know we
create excitement yeah hmm
that's a dog that's a dog that's a doge
all right don't give us a bork bork good
boy Bob the 11 year old Bob did you
forget where the window is
he's in a different room now in his mind
all right are we taking a quiz because I
want to take a quiz dog I finished
school so long ago I'm not taking
quizzes okay we don't have to yeah no
I'm done
good for you pop quizzes plan quizzes
all the above no more quizzes okay
we've taken many quizzes on this podcast
oh that got a quiz I thought you were
saying like a school quiz
I thought you were my teacher for a sec
Ms Moore oh
I'm sorry
um I didn't bring my notes can I see
yours
well
uh one of the one of the streams
recently our chat was taking a love
language test it's like a little quiz
that you take
and it helps you and I think there's
like a partner quiz
and you basically take the test and it
tells you what each person's language of
love is I'm pretty sure I already know
mine and I think I know yours yes before
if if it was possible to have food as a
love language that's Julian's food is oh
I just unplugged my thing food is all
languages for me
I'm fluent in food
we were talking on our vacation was it I
think we were talking about how
like the seven traditional like seven
deadly sins or whatever and which one
affects us the most yeah and mine is
definitely sloth like me and my mom are
the exact same way like if we could just
do nothing that would be so great like I
could do nothing so hard all the time I
love it amazing like my guiltiest
pleasure is just being the laziest
version of myself yeah like you know I
do a lot of stuff work hard but like
when I get an opportunity to be lazy is
like the most engaged oh my God it makes
me so happy and I'm one of my gluttony
gluttony yeah I've never really met
someone with a lust you lust after food
you just like when you get in the zone
of when you're hungry and you're cooking
something that you want like it is you
were so food driven it's a sight to see
I would I would say so myself but like
you will do anything to get the food
that you want I will do anything to get
to the lazy part of the day or so a lot
of what we did in Hawaii was nothing and
eating
because that was our vacation we were
just giving in to to our actual whatever
it is we want
which is fun it's interesting though I
don't know if that's a thing if if
people lean towards one
one deadly sin more than another like I
wonder if there's a quiz for that maybe
there's probably a quiz for that I don't
need a quiz to know what mine is but you
know it's not vanity it's not lust it's
not some of the other ones mine's
definitely vanity it's it's it's it's
slot my deadly sin is sloth it's so not
mine no it's not yours in fact you can't
I couldn't do that if I tried yeah it's
very hard for me to sloth it's like
trying to get okay it's I mean you know
it's like one thing when you're growing
up and you watch how your parents are
and you take on some of those this is
gonna spell for sure you take on some of
their personality traits and behavioral
things and I think I did that to an
extent with my mom but then again I'm
also a little bit the same person as my
mom
I was talking to recently and I was just
like which one of your kids are you most
like and I knew the answer was me but
she was like you and I was like duh but
it was just funny to hear her say that
because she's a very Aries Non-Stop
ratic all over the place person and I'm
exactly the same I'm tamed and I'm
domesticated and I'm in indoor Aries I
used to be in outdoor Aries
but but
video games with Anthony Kong fan the
other day who's he's an outdoors you
first said that to me I was like what
does that mean in outdoor Aries like is
this like a cat and you're like yeah
exactly so Anthony's an outdoor area
he's like he's an outdoor cat like he
just goes and does whatever whatever but
I'm still in Aries I just I live inside
I'm domestic yeah but I used to be what
he is so I know what an outdoor outdoor
Aries is and I've lived that life
yeah
um
anyway
um yeah and like I remember as you know
growing up it was like impossible to get
my mom to just like chill and do one
thing or even just stick to one thing or
a plan or focus on like not a million
things at once and as I grew up into an
adult that was like my problem too so
doing sloth is not only not my deadly
sin but it is very very difficult if I
wanted to I couldn't even do it probably
yeah so anyway language of love before
we get started I want your estimation of
what your language of love is
um you mean aside from sloth I'm kidding
that's not a love language but that's
literally what we were talking about
though like if I did have a love
language it's like doing nothing with
another person so mine I definitely
think because what are what are the Love
Languages there's quality time Gifts of
Acts and Service uh
what are the other ones what are you
doing I'm putting him away from bunny go
in your bed mine is quality time I
actually don't know all of them I just
figured I'd ask because I thought you
did but it's okay mine's totally quality
time I I'm pretty sure almost a thousand
percent I've never taken a quiz but
that's the one that speaks to me the
most quality time and then there's like
gifts right yeah and service service
acts of service gifts okay I think gifts
why don't you look it up well no because
I'm on the website right now I don't
want to lose the page okay
we got to enter our first and last name
what's your first name why do you have
to do that you have to sign up for an
email list as well yeah I'm signing I'm
going to do John aol.com oh damn his
inbox is gonna be hella full Mail 18 to
24. wait that's not my age group 25 to
34 select the country
aland Islands married
have you read the five love languages by
Gary Chapman no
do you want to know
I'm just kidding why would I read it
when I can just take this quiz I'm just
kidding okay
um well here we go
what do you think yours is probably
either acts of service or gifts no no no
no it's not what you do to show love oh
what I what I read as love yes uh you're
right food is not one
um
so my love language when someone does
something for me
I think it's acts of service
I think I feel the most loved and
fulfilled when someone goes out of their
way to help me with something that I
didn't ask them to do but I know that
would mean a lot to me okay we can take
the quiz and then we can learn more
okay
so
this is for couples right yeah yeah it's
for couples okay it's more meaningful to
me when
I think I'm just going to answer these
for me and then maybe you take it
afterwards or something it's more
meaningful to me when a I receive a long
sorry
oh okay it's more meaningful to me when
I receive a loving note slash text email
for no special reason from my loved one
or my partner and I hug
I do like hugs
but I also like being caught off guard
by sweet texts
huh
you're a good hugger
what do you think what I would say
[Laughter]
this is hard you you would appreciate
somebody saying something nice yeah I
think so too it's more meaningful to me
when I can spend alone time with my
partner just the two of us or my partner
does something practical to help me out
oh my God I love me some practicality
I do too but you would answer that you
would answer the alone time thing yeah
I would do the Practical like when you
do something to help me out
it it's amazing like that one time when
you surprised me like flying my best
friend in town for my birthday like
that's sort of thing where I'm like oh
my god oh that's okay that's a little
different that's like that was a gift or
an act of service it was a gift of
active service but you didn't you didn't
buy something from the store and wrap it
and give it to me you thought of
something that would matter to me I
guess they're both Gifts of accident
Services whatever
um it's it's more like taking out the
garbage like I know that's something
practical every day I prefer that you'd
prefer
me take out the garbage Vincent no I
wouldn't prefer it it just means it's
meaningful to me
no I don't know which is a fair example
I totally understand it's one example
but
cooking yeah yeah yeah right or you know
if like
I don't know it's like um
like when I when I found out you wanted
to make me a cake right and you started
to plan that out that whole process for
me was like so cool because I was like
you're gonna spend your time and your
efforts and energy towards building and
making something that is just for me
that that me that is Meaningful thank
you for that you're welcome it's more
meaningful to me when my partner gives
me a little gift
as a token of our love for each other or
I get to spend uninterrupted Leisure
Time with my partner that is the
sentence that has my name written on
interruptive Leisure Time
who wrote that sentence me
I feel like I feel like if I answer some
of these I'm like a bad person
absolutely not that's it's your love
language it's helpful to know exactly
what it is so then you can help
communicate Your Love in a way that
makes sense to that person I mean
uninterrupted leisure time I get down
with that like when we when we don't
have to deal with any other people or
any other things and it's uninterrupted
and we're just together
that's very nice but if I give you a
little gift of something that you
weren't expecting that you really liked
which one makes you feel more loved
well it's I couldn't I can't choose
between the two I can't ow wait I
thought the whole point was to choose
between the two well no it's like but so
if I choose the gift does that mean I'm
never getting love in the other way
again or it's just what I prefer it's
just
I prefer both they're all low I want
them both okay
um you're gonna have to answer the token
I'm gonna do the token yeah it's more
meaningful to me when my partner
unexpectedly does something for me like
filling my car or doing the laundry or
my partner and I touch
well I do like touching you
very much
but I also like when you do my laundry
which you don't
so I I can't really relate to that one
damn right I know touch
laughs
my partner puts his
or her arm around me when we're in
public
I prefer holding hands I don't need you
to like you want me to choke you up I
don't want to get choked or my partner
surprised me with a gift
honestly
put your arm around me in public from
day one I loved
like a healthy amount of PDA
I also like gifts but not you know
it's more meaningful to me when I'm
around my partner even if we're not
doing anything
or I hold hands with my partner
well yeah because one of them's like
touch one of them's contact I I like
being around you like knowing you're in
my space in my vicinity even if we're
not talking or looking at each other
just having you there
um
yeah I prefer that one
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner gives me a gift or I hear I love
you for my partner I love you
means more to me
it's more meaningful to me when I sit
close to my partner or I am complimented
by my loved one for no apparent reason
compliment
I don't need to sit next to you all the
time
we sit next to you I sit next to you
plenty
we are together all the time and we
sleep next to each other and I honestly
if you compliment me for no reason
that's gonna stick out more in my day
than sitting next to you I know you like
that a lot when you when you put on like
a new shirt or something like I love
that shirt you get so excited oh yeah
hell yeah
complimented by no apparent reason it
was apparently
not expected by me
it's more meaningful to me when I get
the chance to just hang out with my
partner or I unexpectedly get small
gifts from my partner
this is back to the gift thing like
um
I don't need things you know what I mean
from you
I it's obviously like if you were to get
me a thing it's like very sweet and
you've done that before and it's nice
but
yeah I prefer hanging out for some
people though that's that's their love
language like the their partner giving
them gifts makes them feel really loved
and appreciated and if that's your love
language and someone's not doing that it
feels like they love you yeah but it's
like when I'll when I'll get you flowers
or something I know you appreciate it
because you do and you're very sweet and
you're like oh this is like very
thoughtful
but I could never get you a bouquet of
quality time and give it to you and have
you have the same reaction you would be
infinitely more happy with the bouquet
of quality time
so if I gave you a bouquet and you knew
that that type of flower entitled you to
like an hour straight of nothing but
quality time right now
didn't matter what flower in the world I
got you you prefer the bouquet of
quality time
anyway I prefer to hang out with my
partner than a gift
why is he licking your arm on your chest
can you you want to put him down he was
screaming Disney is on your lap
it's encouraging in his love language is
sitting on top of it his love language
is is fairly lick you
and then snap at you and you try to
remove him look at that okay what is he
doing it's more meaningful to me when I
hear my partner tell me I'm proud of you
or my partner helps me with the task
Julian's love language is getting Kermit
away from me that makes me feel so loved
when you remove him foreign
[Music]
so I'm proud of you or help me with the
task
proud of you when you say I'm proud of
you it's that's love language for me for
sure
it's more meaningful to me when I get to
do things with my partner or I hear
supportive words from my partner
they're both really meaningful I would
prefer to get to do things with you
though because you're my partner
permit
you told me banish him from this room
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner does things for me instead of
just talking about doing nice things or
I feel connected to my partner through a
hug
connected through a hug that means more
to me
it's more meaningful to me when I hear
Praise from my partner or my partner
gives me something that shows he or she
was really thinking about me
that the latter you the giving me
something that shows that you were
actually really thinking about me that
means a lot yeah yeah
when you bought me the Drone many many
moons ago that was like you you were
thinking about me you were like I have
no reason to be purchasing a drone but
Julian has talked about getting one
and you got me that
yeah I prefer that one it's more
meaningful to me when I'm able to just
be around my partner or I get a back rub
or massage from my partner
I can't relate to the second one
I don't think I've ever gotten a back
rub from you that's not true I've given
you a back rub oh
I forget what it felt like
I prefer that one
um
can I have a background yeah
I love you I love you so much
I'm gonna go with B around my partner
I don't know I feel like as a couple
we don't really do that we don't really
do back rubs it's just it's like it's
trying to narrow down do you value being
touched do you value getting gifts do
you value Quality Time or something oh
that one time that I had a really bad
knot in my arm and you rubbed it out and
I cried because it was so painful that
was love language
yeah why did you pick them up again
because he's just one he's gonna go
bother Bunny and I don't want that but
he's your animal you tell him to sit
down you should sit right how does it
work
is that one what's wrong with this he's
just sitting here no but he's gonna
start looking and he's very close to the
mic
he's not looking if he starts looking
I'll say no
and what will that do exactly I'll pull
my arm away I'll pull my arms up here
okay that sounds fun there's nothing to
lick I'm gonna choose back rub okay I'll
have to give you more back rubs it's
more meaningful thank you it's more
meaningful to me when my partner reacts
positively to something I've
accomplished or my partner does
something for me that I know they don't
particularly enjoy
hmm
I mean you always are supportive over
something I've accomplished always
um and I feel like that's kind of a
given but when I'm time lapsing
something and it's getting cold out and
you're sitting there and I know you
don't want to be sitting there and
that's love I feel like you know what I
mean or if I take you to a jiu jitsu
tournament and you're just like what the
am I doing here but you know I'm
enjoying it that's love so I'm gonna
pick that one thanks
I love suffering
I love when you suffer for me
it's me it's more meaningful to me when
my partner and I kiss frequently
or I sense that my partner is showing
interest in the things I care about kiss
for sure
I like smooches
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner works on special projects with
me that I have to complete or my partner
gives me an exciting gift
well
a gift is always nice but when
when I have like a project to do or a
video to do and I need help and I'm
struggling and stressed and you dedicate
your time and you're like let's do this
and you make me feel reassured
that to me is like
love
you know that shows that you care about
me
you picked that one it's more meaningful
to me when I'm complimented by my
partner on my appearance or my partner
takes the time to listen to me and
really understand my feelings
it's tough I prefer both of those things
I love when you compliment my appearance
don't do don't do that ah what
what do they do just
my parents
um
when you take the time to listen and
understand my feelings I would say is
more important
it's more meaningful to me my partner
and I share non-sexual touches in public
or my partner offers to run errands for
me
fully sexual touches in public only
sexual sexual acts in public oh my God
that was
didn't need to say non-sexual that only
made it more sexual when they wrote that
it's true they could have just said
touch in public oh
no that's do you touch in public
I guess they all kind of sound a little
wrong
public contact like you might get in
trouble
but this is kind of repetitive right
because I already said the PDA thing was
yeah so should I pick that one
should pick whichever one you like more
it's the non-sexual touches I also
prefer sexual
sorry sorry
um more meaningful to me my partner does
a bit more than his or her normal share
of responsibilities we share around the
house work related Etc or I get a gift
that I know my partner put a lot of
thought into choosing um the share the
responsibilities
yeah definitely
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner doesn't check his or her phone
while we're talking
or my partner goes out of their way to
do something that relieves pressure on
me
I'm gonna go with a
it is important when you don't check
your phone while we're talking
it's more meaningful to me when I can
look forward to a holiday because of a
gift I anticipate receiving or I hear
the words I appreciate you
appreciate yeah
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner brings a little gift after he or
she has been traveling without me or my
partner takes care of something I'm
responsible to do but I feel too
stressed to do at the time the second
for sure when you help relieve my stress
that's huge
it's more meaningful to me my partner
doesn't interrupt I was talking
it doesn't interrupt me while I'm
talking or gift giving is an important
part of our relationship
yeah not being interrupted is love I
think letting me finish
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner helps me out when he or she
knows I'm already tired or I get to go
somewhere while spending time with my
partner
acts of service like helping me out is
huge so yes that one
it's more meaningful when my partner and
I are physically intimate or my partner
gives me a little gift that he or she
picked up over the course of their
normal day intimate
what we're adults
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner says something encouraging to me
or I get to spend time in a shared
activity or a hobby
kind of hobbies that we do together
play video games together we walk the
dogs
jiu jitsu
when we roll around and you're in a ghee
screaming that you hate it that's love
I would say says something encouraging
to me
it's more meaningful when my partner
surprises me with a small token of their
appreciation or my partner and I touch a
lot throughout the normal course of a
day
touch a lot
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner helps me out especially if I
know they're already busy or I hear my
partner specifically tell me I
appreciate you
that helps me out thing yeah well if you
if you know I'm stressed or busy and you
decide to spend your time helping me
that's love for me
uh it's more meaningful when my partner
and I embrace after we've been apart for
a while or I hear my partner say how
much I mean hit to him or her Embrace
yeah like when I would come home from a
trip and we hug that's yeah
hey hey
finish the birdies your scores
number nine
physical touch that's at the top seven
acts of service six quality time six
words of affirmation two receiving gifts
your love language personal profile
the highest score indicates your primary
love language the highest score is 12.
it's not uncommon to have two high
scores which I kind of do nine and seven
uh although one love one language does
have a slight Edge for most people that
just means two languages are important
to you the lower score indicates those
languages you seldom use to communicate
love and which probably don't affect you
on an emotional level
learn more about your primary love
language and how to put it to use
next to the corresponding badge below
okay so I can read through all these but
I'll read physical touch
physical touch this language isn't all
about the bedroom
a person's primary language is physical
touch is not surprisingly very touchy
hugs pats on the back holding hands and
thoughtful touches on the arm shoulder
or face can always be ways to show
excitement concern care and love
physical presence and accessibility are
crucial while neglect or abuse can be
unforgivable and destructive
physical touch Fosters a sense of
security and belonging in any
relationship that sounds accurate to me
and I'm not surprised that that came at
the top of the list my second highest is
acts of service which I'm also not
surprised can vacuuming the floors
really be an expression of Love
absolutely anything you do to ease the
burden of responsibilities Weighing on
an acts of service person will speak
volumes the words he or she most wants
to hear is let me do that for you
laziness broken commitments and making
more work for them tell speakers of this
language that their feelings don't
matter finding ways to serve speaks
volumes to the recipient of these acts
well there you go and then quality time
words of affirmation both are tied for
third and then receiving gifts is and
last
That's My love language
I feel like I knew a lot of that I did
too I think but it's kind of nice to go
through and have it be like yeah you
know
shown back to me it's like I'm looking
at a mirror of love
what
you're just funny
um by the way we can link this website
but the website that we can't link is
the Squarespace website that you build
yourself Juliet squarespace.com Jen and
Julian to get 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain what's
Squarespace oh it's only the best
platform to build a website on whatever
website you might want to build whether
it's for your small business or a little
hobby photography whatever you're into
and you want to build a website for do
it with Squarespace it's incredibly easy
they have a customer service team that's
there for you 24 hours a day seven days
a week they're always there for you they
even have
um online live webinars that you can
watch and learn all sorts of different
tricks and techniques to make your
website stand out
there's customization all the way from
the color and the template and the way
your website will look with the fonts
and everything down to how it looks on
different devices and what features it
has with an online shop or store or uh
what's clickable what's not and you you
learn all of that through the process of
using their service like the Squarespace
service or also using their customer
service while you're at it and it's it's
a really really awesome way to build the
website so if you're putting it off and
you're like that's too complicated for
me try it out go to squarespace.com if
you're not ready to commit to it do the
free trial see how you like it uh can't
say enough good things Squarespace is an
awesome sponsor of the podcast and a
really great way to build a website
um
and me Andy's a really great way to
build confidence and comfort in debt but
and that but you put your me undies on
and you're already doing better than you
were a second ago because you didn't
have me on these on so if you add me
into the equation of any day it's like
three points better immediately
Mandy's is a really awesome
product they are three times softer than
cotton
micro modal fabric makes no sense until
you actually feel it because then it's
like oh that's what that feels like
they have onesies bralettes socks undies
they have couples pairs where you can
buy one for you and your loved one that
match and the styles that you each
prefer they have subscription Services
is a very very very awesome service and
they come out with new prints all the
time too so they're always keeping it
fresh and exciting I literally wear
nothing but mandies every single day nor
does Jenna like only Mandy's for us and
we love them so give it a try go to me
undies.com Julian saved 15 off your
first pair
free shipping and they guarantee you'll
like it it's a guarantee
your turn
sure thank you sponsors I know what all
of the dogs love languages are well
bunny we're still figuring out
I cuddled with bunny for the first time
I feel like dogs have love language
Marbles and Kermit are both just like
physical touch and praise non-stop it
does so much for them Peach is just food
food then physical touch and praise I
feel like praise doesn't do as much for
peachy she likes touch more than praise
but like Kermit if you speak nicely to
him and say nice things to him it's like
the sun is beaming down on him like he
couldn't be happier
I know it's funny it's so true though
Peach literally if you feed her food she
loves you forever more than anything
ever and if Kermit you you tend to his
needy neediness and give him
reaffirmation and and you're telling him
he's a good boy and keep his confidence
level above water then you are a god
and marbles if you just sit with him and
pet him and cuddle him then he's super
happy all you need to do to win marbles
over is be next to him and be there for
him for probably like 12 years straight
and then he'll love you
just put a little time in you love you
so you pretty much just like click it
and it'll scroll to the Next One
automatically
all right it's more meaningful to me
when I receive a long loving note or
text message or my partner and I hug I
would say the the long-loving note
mine's the same as yours
uh it's more meaningful when I can spend
alone time with my partner just the two
of us are my partner does something
practical to help me out they're both
like I'd say the acts of service and
quality time are both very important to
me but the alone time
yep not surprising there hmm
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner gives me a little gift to as a
token of our love for each other or I
get to spend uninterrupted Leisure Time
with my partner that is my favorite
sentence
that is my ideal day
uninterrupted Leisure Time with my
partner that sentence is my love that's
your city yeah
gifts don't do a lot for me they really
don't I mean it's really sweet and
really nice it's one of the most
frustrating things like I'm so good at
getting gifts I know I just like I've
they've always sort of like made me a
little uncomfortable like when somebody
gets me something it like makes me feel
a little like you really didn't have to
do that you know like I I feel bad now
you know
I I get I I get that feeling though I
understand that
but it's really I like it it's nice but
it's definitely not my love language at
all it's more meaningful to me when my
partner unexpectedly does something for
me like filling my car or doing the
laundry or my partner and I touch
fill in my car boy oh my God I swear
every time my mom comes to town the two
of you take my car and like go fix it
for me because yeah it's just so that's
that's the one you prefer yeah okay
services
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner puts his or her arm around me
when we're in public or my partner
surprises me with a gift
not only when you put your arm around me
in public but when you just you grab my
my shirt sleeves and then we start doing
full Jiu Jitsu in public you know you
know to the point where one of us has to
attack that does not happen
when you put your arm around me yeah
it's more meaningful to me when I'm
around my partner even if we're not
really doing anything or I hold hands
with my partner around
I love holding your hands sometimes it
gets too hot and sweaty and I gotta let
go sorry being around you though is my
favorite thing yeah
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner gives me a gift or I hear I love
you for my partner
definitely going with I love you
it's more meaningful to me when I sit
close to my partner or I am complimented
by my loved one for no apparent reason
that makes me uncomfortable I want to
sit right next to you well when I
compliment you when I'm like hey babe
your butt looks good today what did you
say to me the other day that I'm like
really good at dodging compliments oh I
was like yeah you're like pound for
pound the best compliment Dodger in the
world I like to say close to you I think
I think I was like
after a night of Siege I was like you're
actually owning tonight
like you were you're playing incredibly
well or pubg or whatever and you're like
no no no no no no no we're you know I
was just I was I was just playing normal
I was like no no that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying like you actually
played really well tonight and I'm
telling you that not as like being nice
but like you're actually you own tonight
you're like no no no no no no no I
wasn't I'm like why are we fighting
about this this is not this is not like
an observation or an opinion this is the
fact you were doing well
that's that
you can't take it you're like no I
wasn't no we were all doing well I think
we're all doing I think we're all doing
well
I like to sit close to you if I could
sit like so that it was bothering you as
well you do that you do do that
it's more meaningful to me when I get
the chance just to hang out with my
partner
wow or I unexpectedly get small gifts
from my partner I just want to hang out
easy choice just want to hang out it's
more meaningful to me when I hear my
partner tell me I'm proud of you or my
partner helps me with a task helps me
with a task boy oh my god when you do
the dishes or you cook up one of those
Aries meals I'm like oh my God you are
just the best you're the actual best
sometimes it gets real messy and it gets
wild but like when you go out of your
way to do stuff like that it is my
favorite because you as much as you do
you do a lot that is helpful you are
very helpful
as much as I rag on you for being a mess
and a tornado thank you you're
incredibly helpful it's one of the most
satisfying things for me
is is making you food and you tasting it
and saying wow like this is actually
very good you know like I don't know
that that to me is like that's
I could tell you enjoy that yeah well
even like when you feed the dogs or
we'll be like who's gonna feed the dogs
and you're just like I'll go do it I'm
like oh he's sweet ah so I could sit
here and and sloth some more for real I
mean that's honestly most most days so
it's
back when we started doing you know like
farmer's dog and like we would have
turns feeding the dogs and it became
kind of a production
um we would do it sort of like I would
do one day you would do another day I
would do one day and then on weeks when
I was going out of town I would pretty
much do it the whole week so that the
weekend when you had to do it all
yourself you kind of had you know we
traded off yeah but now and then it was
like on Wednesdays I'll feed the dogs
because you're working or whatever but
now it's like
I kind of just feed the dogs that's not
true I feed them plenty no you do but we
used to do like yieldy breakfast I'll do
dinner and then it turns into okay
Julian did Back to say it didn't it but
it's not even like I don't mind it
because it's like if I feed them
breakfast and then it's your turn to
feed them dinner technically and I'm
like waiting around for it I'm like I
just can't not do it I'm like all right
I'm gonna feed him I got it I'll do it
I'd rather get it done it's like it's
more peaceful to me if it's done than
having you actually do it at this point
too like it used to feel like a chore to
feed three dogs and like keep them
separate like it took a while to get
them all used to eating in the same
space like it was a lot the routine was
hard to learn and then it you know it
eventually turned into like an okay
thing but it's whatever but then since
we got bunny it's sort of like weirdly
easier it's somehow easier it was harder
for the first couple weeks because then
it's like she eats in a separate room
and you know she eats different food
it's like it's a lot but at this point
they all are you know sensing that
there's a bigger dog I swear they all
eat in four seconds now she is so easy
to feed she's a dog she's a dog and also
you know I think like like weirdly it's
easier now than with for than it was
with three like I'll take her into the
room pour her her kibble in there close
the game she's drooling she's ready to
go close the gate it takes exactly the
amount of time for her to finish her
food that it does for me to feed the
little ones right so I feed them come
back let her out right she goes outside
and then by the time she's done doing
her business they're done eating and
it's like super easy it is yeah whereas
before it was like stand around coddle
marbles while he's upset that the other
dogs well him getting his teeth out
helps a lot too there you go because he
would just stand there and like
everything needed to be broken up super
small and he was like nervous someday
you could tell his mouth was hurting him
it was just it was a lot but it is
somehow easier now with four dogs weird
and how that works but but when you feed
them and like you really sweet
plus it also they all bond with you more
I'll tell you one thing marbles started
like me more when I was feeding him see
exactly right my dude can I pet you my
hands
that's like when the food's coming from
you they're like wow thank you thank you
so much that's so nice yeah
look at me
I'm the chef now
okay it's more meaningful to me when I
get to do things with my partner or I
hear supportive words for my partner
I love you so much but I I don't need
supportive words I know I just want your
friendship I know that
it's more meaningful I mean I do I like
supportive words but I just like hanging
out more it's more meaningful to me when
my partner does things for me instead of
just talking about doing nice things or
I feel connected to my partner through a
hug
uh when you do things yeah
I like hugs too don't get me wrong but
sometimes I'm like you're squishing my
hair and I'm thinking about 20 million
things I have to do and like let
me go because it's actually 100 degrees
out right now well it's 100 degrees in
this hug
exactly right men
very hot
it's more meaningful to me
until I hear Praise from my partner
or my partner gives me something that
shows me he or she was really thinking
about me
I guess this is hard because I don't
really need either of those
gives me something that shows I really
like that like you know flowers or
something yeah but it's not like a gift
but something that was like thoughtful
that you were really thinking about me
but I mean I like crazy
Japanese outfits for Kermit yeah um that
was so incredible there was that website
I do works or whatever they're only in
Japan and this was like forever ago when
they didn't ship anywhere there was
nothing like it online and I found it
and I was obsessed with it but it was
all in Japanese so you literally used
like a translation to order it and have
them ship it to the US and got you at
like that was Next Level legendary
thinking about me that was very sweet
did it to you
it wasn't even for me it was a
turtleneck for Kermit which he hated he
hated tried to actually lose it on
purpose
but it meant a lot to me
it's more meaningful to me when I'm able
just to be around my partner or I get a
rub or massage from my partner you hate
you don't know you don't want to get
around I don't want I do sometimes
obviously like anybody it's nice to be
touched but like I just want to be
around you that's the end-all be-all for
me and sometimes when you touch me it
hurts
all right my favorite is like too rough
you'll have slept on your neck wrong and
you're like can you please rub my neck
on I'll be doing it and you're just like
after like five minutes of just non-stop
like rubbing your neck you're just like
okay thanks and I'm like
was that was that indicative of how you
felt the whole time
now
okay thanks thank you just like
um hurts you're so like rough I'm gentle
you're not you're the opposite of gentle
oh marble
that's what I feel like
that's me marble is me he's happy yeah
but you scare him and like you're too
much for him sometimes
you should touch me like a little piece
of paper you know like if if you do it
too rough you it's gonna rip that's me
thank you that's nice
it's like telling a child how to pet a
dog sometimes and they're like am I
doing it and they're just like holding
their ear and ripping it
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner reacts positively to something
I've accomplished or my partner does
something for me that I know they don't
particularly enjoy
oh boy
I do it's very nice when you react
positively to something I've
accomplished and I don't I don't like
when you're not enjoying yourself I'm
constantly like are you okay is this
what's wrong I I hate when you get in
that state and you just like shut down
and and you're like not having a good
time but you also won't like explicitly
tell me that you're not what if I'm
doing it so I know you can have a good
time
yeah like go to Sephora yes exactly but
that doesn't make me happy to bring you
in there and watch you put every
lipstick on your hand or take your hand
and swipe them across all of them I've
never done mistakes
I'd say when you react positively to
something I've accomplished I don't
really like when you're like not having
or not you're doing something that you
don't enjoy it doesn't make me happy
yeah fair enough I I identify with that
I actually didn't really think of that
because like that Dynamic where you know
you're enjoying something but you know
the person who you love who's with you
isn't it it takes away from the
experience yeah you're like all
in the back of your mind you're like
they're not having fun I appreciate that
you're doing it but I also like it it's
it doesn't like mean a lot to me I just
I want to do it and get it over with so
that we can get back to you not being
yeah like at Sephora I'm like all right
give me seven minutes and you're like
okay and you'll go distract yourself or
whatever and then I'm like in and out of
there it doesn't make me feel like
particularly loved that you're coming
into Sephora with me you know yeah I
know you don't like it we'll just get it
over with and then live
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner and I kiss frequently or I sense
my partner is showing interest in the
things that I care about this on the
other hand I love it like when I was sit
and talk to you about plants or like
whatever it is I'm watching on YouTube
and hanging out and you're interested
and you're listening and I love that
even though I know you don't care that's
sweet to me
you're being feral
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner works on special projects with
me that I have to complete or my partner
gives me an exciting gift
definitely special projects that's
absolutely yeah we work together a lot
and I really enjoy that it's more
meaningful to me when I've I'm
complimented by my partner on my
appearance or my partner takes time to
listen and really understand my feelings
definitely that one I could look like a
whole bag of hell and I do not
care if you like my hair or my eyelashes
or whatever the when you take the
time to listen to me that is my love
language yeah
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner and I share non-sexual touch in
public
my partner offers to run errands for me
dream come true
easy peasy easiest decision of my life I
enjoy doing that get your hands
off me and why don't you go to the
grocery store and get some
kidney beans fair enough okay
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner does a bit more than his or her
normal share of responsibilities that is
so amazing or I get a gift absolute
responsibilities
all these are completely unsurprising
yeah yeah I'm a I'm a pretty predictable
impractical person think very much it's
called be a Virgo it's more meaningful
to me when my partner doesn't check his
or her phone while we're talking or my
partner goes out of their way to do
something that relieves pressure on me
hmm
I'd say when you don't check your phone
yeah I think that's honestly kind of a
universal thing yeah if you're talking
to someone that you love and they're on
their phone you're like but I think
that's sort of narrowing down which do I
value more quality time or uh acts of
service which to me is quality time
it's more meaningful to me when I can
look forward to a holiday because of a
gift don't give a or I hear the
words I appreciate you for my partner
definitely the words
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner brings me a little gift no after
he or she's been traveling without me
that's really sweet though like when you
get me a shirt that says wherever you
wear it like those that's really nice or
I definitely like it more when you get
when you bring the dogs little toys that
makes me so happy
wow my partner takes care of something
I'm responsible to do but I feel too
stressed to do at the time that is like
when I'm in the middle of stuff and
you're just like all right I'm gonna go
run do this really quick or you do
something around the house that needs to
get done like when we turn into Hotel J
and J and I have like 11 000 things to
do and you're like I already cleaned the
sheets in the guest room and did the
pillows or I'm like oh dude thank you so
much like I love you you're the
best yeah that means the world to me
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner doesn't interrupt me while I'm
talking or gift giving is an important
part of our relationship
when you don't interrupt me even if like
anything against gift giving is an
important part of a relationship would
win anything that's not an important
part of it it's not for me no but
there's also nothing wrong with people
that have that really no I feel like
that's enough I mean everyone's
different and everyone's relationship is
different I think honestly
like I don't know like thinking of like
if your love language was gift giving
right and I would go get you a gift and
you'd be like this is so beautiful thank
you or I'd feel like you didn't love me
unless you got me a little gift yeah
it's just a whole different Dynamic yeah
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner helps me out when he or she
knows I'm already tired oh my God or I
get to go somewhere while spending time
with my partner that's my favorite one
there's so many like Saturdays or
Sundays and I'm like let's just go like
we'll we'll go get some breakfast and
then maybe go to the dog park go for a
walk like that's the time that I really
look forward to all week because even
though we're here together all the time
like the time that we're just doing
nothing but spending time together is my
favorite yeah
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner and I are physically intimate or
my partner gives me a little gift
that he or she picked up in the course
of the normal day
I'm I'm gonna
say physically
because I don't I don't
I don't really want a gift but if we
could lay lay on the couch together
intimately and cuddle intimately like
the friends that we are they're very
intimate
in a non-sexual in public touch in a
private and sexual
oh my God
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner says something encouraging to me
or I get to spend time in shared
activity or a hobby with my partner
shared activities definitely time
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner surprises me with a small token
of their appreciation or my partner and
I touch a lot
during the course for a normal day I'd
say when we touch a lot it's fun
high fives high fives and handshakes
only
[Laughter]
nice when we deliberately shake hands
with each other at least 11 times in one
single day when we're laying on the
couch next to each other and we reach
over and shake hands
my favorite
when I wake you up in the morning by
grabbing your hand and shaking it and
saying good morning
thank you for waking me up
[Laughter]
standing down here still staring at me
it's more meaningful to me when my
partner helps me out especially if I
know they're already busy or uh you're
you tell me specifically I appreciate
you definitely when you help me out even
if I know you're busy
it's definitely more uh it's more
meaningful to me when my partner and I
embrace after we've been apart for a
while or I hear my partner say how much
I mean to him or her those are both so
sweet though yeah it's hard to choose
hey Kermit get in your bed in your bed I
I'm with you and I say embrace
although I really like when you say how
much you mean to me
not what you mean to me yeah yeah
actually I'm gonna go with that one that
probably does I love giving you a hug
after I haven't seen you in a while yeah
but who doesn't that's like but like if
we had to be like I hadn't seen you in a
while and I had a choice between either
get a hug but I don't get to talk to you
or uh we get to be separated but I get
to talk to you but I don't get to touch
you I'd rather talk to you yeah that
seems not where I am
my score
12 quality time yep eight acts of
service five words of affirmation four
physical Touch One receiving gifts one
receiving gifts I don't care I don't
want anything yeah
um
yeah quality time
in the vernacular of quality of time
quality time nothing says I love you
like full undivided attention just like
you Carmen yeah that's your love
language being there for this type of
person is critical but really being
there with the TV off fork and knife
down all chores and tasks on standby
make your significant other feel truly
special and love distractions postpone
dates or the failure to listen can be
especially hurtful quality time means
sharing quality conversation and quality
activities for me it's like less
activities and more like conversation
you know like when we sit in talkers
yeah you love that I love that
acts of service is the same as yours
yeah I've already read that one you mean
yeah
well there you go those are a love
language I mean honestly nothing
surprising here
I think it's nice to read that though
and it was fun to take the test because
it
it's like well I'll have to shake your
hand more because yours is physical
touch well that was my second place no
it was your first place I thought
is it was it my first place maybe it was
yeah it was I already forgot I thought
it was uh
acts of service no that was your second
one oh well oh they were both kind of up
there though like it was nine and seven
mine were very split I didn't have like
a front runner
you know I had like a couple first
places but yeah you're right physical
touch so yeah could you shake my hand a
little bit more let's up it from 12 to
15 times a day
I love you
I love you too friend
do some of this
it's making you feel loved
so loved so much love right now it's
just flowing through my arms to you and
backwards
oh
he forgets where he is peek-a-boo what
were you mad at Julie come here
hey mister I'll I'll have to give you
some more physical touch and some more
acts of service and I'll have to do a
better job of
uh well no a continuously continuously
improving job of listening and talking
to you and having quality time
right remember
he's so cute he is cute but it is really
nice to know because it's you know I
think a lot of people's relationships
suffer when they don't understand what
means the most to their partner yeah
they base it off of what means the most
to them they're like you know for
someone who loves gifts they're like if
I get you know if I love gifts and I get
you a gift love is love right you're
going to enjoy that but why aren't you
happy it's language of love is very
important it is very important I think
if you've been in a relationship with
someone for an extended period of time
even if you may not like explicitly you
know
um do a perfect job of fulfilling
someone's love language you deep down
have an idea of it you know just from
being with someone you understand what
makes them happy and if you really think
about it you can kind of deduce their
language of love without even taking
this test or talking to them or anything
you just think about it right like what
you know what makes them the happiest
yeah but I mean it totally sucks if
you're non-stop buying someone gifts and
all they really want is some quality
time but they don't understand you know
you're just like I'm broke it feels like
spend so much money on gifts and you
don't even like them you don't even like
me you hate me they are I honestly
quality time is one is one that
obviously
it's not it's not my number one and
learning to fulfill that language of
love is a process is from someone like
me and so it's
it's rounded me out a little bit as a
person you know a little more
well-rounded from
loving you like that
more back rubs for both of us okay no no
I don't need any back rubs I'll give you
back rubs okay fine I literally am fine
I do not need a violent back rub from
you so foot rub foot rub would be fine
okay can I can I do it with my feet
foot on foot
million
foot rubs with my feet okay we can try
that's actually a cool business idea
feet for feet and you give foot rubs
with feet I feel like this is a fetish
thing oh that could very very well turn
into a creepy fetish thing never mind
I'm gonna I'm gonna redact that from the
podcast
you didn't just hear that it's redacted
redacted
there's this whole podcast has been
this is a black thumbnail just nothing
redacted redacted
um well this is fun this was fun and
marble thank you the most for letting us
do this and guys thank you for hanging
out and listening and watching another
podcast thank you Squarespace thank you
me undies thank you to our sponsors our
wonderful sponsors and addition to our
sponsors which you should definitely
click below I'm gonna include the
website that we use for our love
language so y'all can figure out what
y'alls is and tell us y'all's love
language tell us y'alls and we'll see
you guys next week go love each other
and be good bye and shake hands
in that bye
[Music]